امتثال اول رئيس امريكي امام القضاء
رافقته موجه من الاراء المتضاربه حول
تاثير القضيه على ترامب المترشح
الا ان القصه التي تروي اصوله لهذه
المرحله باتت واحده وبدايتها كانت ذات يوم
من يوليو عام 2006 مع الممثله الاباحيه
ستورميدانينز لقاء في ملعب جولد تلاته
صوره تذكاريه ثم دعوه للعشاء العنوان لم
يكن مطعما شهيرا بل غرفه فندق في بحيره
تاهو اللقاء الحميمي دام ثلاث ساعات ولم
يكن لهما بعدا لم ترضى بثمن لا يتناسب مع
وزن الزبون الى ان اثمرت المفاوضات ب 130
الف دولار دفعها مايكل كوهن مقابل دفن
السر ومصدر الاموال يبقى مقصد القضيب
ترامب صار رئيسا ولم يعد ينفع مع دانيلز
مال ولا تهديد المواجهه دخلت المحاكم وكل
ما يسعى اليه الدفاع ترامب الان هو تاجيل
الحكم الى ما بعد الانتخابات للقضاء راي
اخر مدعما حاتم العام ينوي غلق القضيه قبل
الانتخابات وهنا يدخل ترامب نفقا بمخرجين
براءه او حتى ادانه دون ايداع قد يقوده
للبيت الابيض
ومصير اخر تفرضه ادانه مع ايداع الفوري في
السجن وهنا نهايه طموحاته السياسيه